ce volet du meilleur james qui s'est
livré à un exercice qu'il maîtrise
plutôt bien ce n'est pas son premier
discours devant un parlement les
etats-unis l'italie l'allemagne ou
encore israël il maîtrise l'exercice et
à chaque fois il essaye de s'adapter aux
pays et aux références du pays en
l'occurrence là il a parlé notamment de
verdun pour
comparer les différents champs de
bataille oui absolument à chaque fois il
fait une fait référence effectivement
historique pour faire un parallèle entre
ce que vit son pays et son peuple avec
ce qu'a pu vivre le peuple du parlement
auquel ils s'adressent les ruines de
verdun at-il at-il évoqué delà de la
première guerre mondiale on aurait pu
imaginer aussi des références à la
résistance française qui est ce qu'un
parallèle qu'il n'a pas qu'il n'a pas
fait il a parlé aussi des anciens
survivants de l'holocauste mais c'est un
volodymyr zelensky qui par rapport au
premier le discours qu'il a fait part
aux premiers appels à l'aide a baissé en
ambition par par réalisme parce qu il
faut savoir que oui il a demandé déjà
beaucoup de choses il a demandé
une aide militaire directe qui n'a pas
obtenu une zone d'exclusion aérienne qui
n'a pas obtenu des avions de chasse il
ne les a pas obtenu et à force de se
voir refuser par ces parlements qui tous
disent soyez sûr monsieur que nous
sommes à vos côtés à côté de vos peuples
il a abaissé ses ambitions alors il
finit en disant qu'est ce que nous
attendons de la france du leadership
français d'une part que la france
intervienne auprès de la russie pour que
la russie cherche la paix il a demandé
la même chose à peu près aux chinois à
la turquie à israël c'est à dire à
plusieurs pays fait les intermédiaires
user de votre influence internationale
pour réussir à obtenir des négociations
ça c'est le premier point ensuite il y a
quand même ils fixent ces lignes rouges
aussi l'intégrité territoriale de la rue
de la l'ukraine doit être rétablie c'est
une ligne rouge la sécurité aussi de
l'ukraine doit être garantie et ça c'est
aussi une ligne rouge paquet de ces deux
des plus tueur négociations saga qu'à un
moment donné il a été par exemple la
question
d'une neutralité de l'ukraine ou
peut-être d'un partage de l'ukraine pour
volodymyr zelensky il faut que
absolument la gala à la la la la la la
la sécurité de son pays soit garanti et
il compte sur la france pour que ce soit
entendu alors maintenant il rappelle
quand même que oui son pays a besoin d'
aide a besoin de l'aide militaire deux
chars de défense aérienne mais surtout
il demande plus de sanctions et là il a
visé plus spécifiquement un certain
nombre d'entreprises françaises qui
continue à faire du congrès ce qui l'a
cité qui fait continuer à faire du
commerce en ukraine à savoir j'en cite
un certain nombre au chant leroy merlin
notamment et encore et renault en disant
voilà il faut qu'elle arrête de faire
parce que la stratégie c'est à défaut
d'avoir une aide militaire massive au
moins que les stands hongrie comme des
dingues aille jusqu'au bout et c'est ce
qu'il avait demandé également devant le
sénat américain que toutes les
entreprises américaines se retirent du
marché russe pour que la pression
économique se fasse sentir de plus en
plus côté français on est prêts on est
prêt à quoi on est prêt à kehl à quels
sacrifices pour aider l'ukraine ben on
est prêt à pas grand chose pour
l'instant j'ai l'impression surtout que
dans trois semaines trois quatre
semaines premier tour des élections
présidentielles la grande discussion
c'est le pouvoir d'achat des français là
une des mesures principales que pourrait
prendre la france c'est évidemment un
embargo sur le gaz ou le pétrole russe
or on sait très bien que et la france et
l'union européenne dans son ensemble
sont dépendants à 40 % pour le gaz 30%
pour le pétrole de la russie et que pour
le moment cette stratégie n'est pas
encore envisagée en revanche oui des
sanctions spécifiques contre les
oligarques des sanctions contre certains
produits russes sont sont prises et
l'étau se resserre au fur à mesure il
n'ya la livraison de matériel aussi
militaire qui se fait mais au-delà de ça
et malgré les déclarations
de du président
du sénat et du président de l'assemblée
nationale et malgré là ce qu'on appelle
standing-ovation c'est à dire le fait
que tous les parlementaires se lève pour
saluer le président ukrainien
l'assurance que le peuple français et le
parlement français sont aux côtés du
président non la france n'est pas prête
à aller sinon axa virginie vous suivez
pour nous cette gare en ukraine vous
suivez également pour nous cette
campagne présidentielle en quoi la
guerre en ukraine s'invite dans la
campagne présidentielle en quad la
perturbe l la perturbe parce que tout
est déjà là ella ella elle l'a reportée
disons cette campagne cette campagne
finalement on l'entend qu'en filigrane
parce que c'est la grosse actualité
effectivement internationale qui a
favorisé d'ailleurs le président m'a
conquis à gagner plusieurs points dans
les sondages en apparaissant comme comme
le chef le chef de guerre a été saluée
par vladimir jeunes inscrits dans son
discours qui a été aussi saluée par
effectivement par zelensky qui fait
quand même qui rend hommage à tout tout
tout tout les tous les chefs d'état et
les chefs de gouvernement qui montre
quand même une forme de solidarité
mais donc d'une part ça a favorisé donc
le candidat au pouvoir à savoir emmanuel
macron et d'autre part ça a perturbé
aussi la campagne surtout de ceux qui
étaient disons le plus russophiles ou en
tout cas qui s'était
montré le plus proche de
marine le pen eric zemmour également
mélenchon également qu'ils ont dû un peu
revoir leur position leur position par
rapport à moscou certains avaient dit
carrément leur admiration par rapport à
ce candidat un petit peu autorités risée
sur les analystes
oui oui peut-être malgré malgré leur
position normalement
souverainiste
anti-américaine aussi et donc peut-être
plus proche plus proche de moscou pour
eux en tout cas ça a été effectivement
une très mauvaise nouvelle cette cette
grande brune merci beaucoup